all right let's talk about hillsdale
when i was considering going to college
my 18 year old self was quite
overwhelmed i wasn't sure what exactly i
wanted in a college i visited i visited
and i met with some professors i fell in
love pretty fast everyone really was so
welcoming people are really passionate
about what they're learning i really was
drawn by the challenge it presented i'm
going to be completely honest with you
hillsdale can be really challenging one
thing hillsdale's big on is the liberal
arts you learn a lot of different things
from different fields philosophy
theology history and the great books
classes math science western heritage
the western tradition zozo has really
great conversation between courses that
you'll take the liberal arts is
fundamentally answering the question of
what it is to be a human being but what
makes it so worthwhile are the people
and the friendships that you make along
the way in all of my experiences with
professors they're always very
approachable they're willing to help
students professors interact with one
another and really care for one another
the professors know you by name and know
your story hillsdale has something
unique to offer it's a place to work on
reordering your soul when i came on a
campus i just felt like i had finally
found a place where i could be i could
call home i wanted to learn how to be a
great leader to be a great person and
hillsdale through their education
definitely teaches you how to do that
it's the best decision
i've ever made in my entire life
[Music]